let me be clear for those who don't seem
to know slavery was the cause of the
Civil War there's no negotiation about
that now now we're living in an era of a
second loss cause once again there are
some in this country trying trying to
turn a loss into a lie a lie which if
allowed to live will once again bring
terrible damage to this country
President Biden in Charleston South
Carolina governor haly welcome clearly
want to start there the first part of
that sound bite was pretty much aimed at
you and your answer in that New
Hampshire town hall about the cause of
the Civil War you've since explained
that slavery was the cause but what's
your reaction to the president going to
the mother Emanuel am Church a church in
Charleston you often talk about and he
said to go after you and what he called
Maga Republicans led by a defeated
president I mean first of all mother
Emanuel Church is a sacred place I mean
we had we lost nine amazing Souls that
night for just going to a Bible study
and I will tell everybody those amazing
people all 12 of them when someone else
showed up that didn't look like them or
act like them or sound like them they
didn't call the
cops they didn't throw him out instead
they pulled up a chair and prayed with
him for an hour
and when they bowed their heads in that
last prayer he began to shoot these were
people like Ethel Lance who had just
lost her daughter two years prior to
breast cancer but she would go around
mother Emanuel Church singing One Day at
a Time Sweet Jesus that's all I ask of
you give me the strength to do every day
what I have to do Taiwan Sanders our
youngest victim had just graduated
college and on that night he St stood in
front of his 87-year-old great aunt
Susie and looked at the Killer and said
you don't have to do this we mean no
harm to you or it was someone like
Cynthia herd whose life motto was simply
to be kinder than necessary that's who
these people were for Biden to show up
there and give a political speech is
offensive in itself but the second thing
I'll say is I don't need someone who ped
around with segregationists in the 70s
and has said racist comments all the way
through his career lecturing me or
anyone in South Carolina about what it
means to have racism slavery or anything
related to the Civil
War hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else